[Music]
welcome welcome back to CBS this morning
multi-platinum country music trio that
of course is Lady Antebellum has a long
history of success the seven-time Grammy
Award winners have sold more than listen
to this number 18 million albums thank
you very much and have earned nine
number-one hits so only on CBS this
morning we love when we can say that so
I'm going to say it again only on CBS
this morning
Lady Antebellum joins us to reveal the
top nominees for the 52nd Academy of
Country Music Awards those awards honor
the biggest names and talent in country
music helps with earrings Hilary Scott
and Dave Kate will join us at the table
good morning to you guys start us off
with the male vocalist of the okay we're
so excited to do this okay male vocalist
of the Year nominees are Jason Aldean
Dierks Bentley Thomas Rhett who's also
gonna be a daddy this year that's a big
year for you okay Chris Stapleton and
Keith Urban
that's an all-star cast up next number
two female vocalist of the year Charles
I'm an expert in this Kelsea Ballerini
she's actually going Miranda Lambert yay
vice mayor and Morris Kacey Musgraves
and of course Carrie Underwood that's
Dave the third category is Entertainer
of the Year this is this is the big one
this is the big one Jason Aldean Luke
Bryan good buddy from Georgia Florida
Georgia line um Carrie Underwood and
Keith Urban Wow Wow all right fourth
category Vocal Duo of the year I'm sorry
you guys are not eligible because
they're free but Hillary thing were the
nominees the nominees are big and rich
brothers Osbourne dan + Shay Florida
Georgia line and Maddie and Tay
any of the any of the categories so far
as anything stood out to you that you go
I know X is gonna win Oh
so good I yeah you know and you're
probably friends with them too yeah
really proud of Brothers Osborne has had
a really big breakout year yeah I'm glad
to see those guys in there so is Maren
Morris I thought I think it's I really
do think it's her year this year yeah
yeah I think she's awesome but we have
one more this is vocal group of the year
let's see Eli Young Band Little Big Town
mm-hmm
Old Dominion mm-hmm Rascal Flatts and
one more who is it we heard number one I
think country music singers are the
nicest nicest people we talk about that
all day don't you think and I know you
can't stereotype but really you guys in
your industry are really something else
you remember what it was like when you
won your first award in this category
yes
ACM Awards it goes best award we ever
won never wasn't ACN what was that night
like oh my gosh I just remember never I
was always holding look at you yeah
that's nice I was like for every award
show my wife always called me like
interrupting cow I'm just like come in
here it's amazing it's been that long
already I can't believe it yeah you know
it's funny like now - I guess what is
2017 and you know we're all married we
each have a kid each and black on the
road is definitely different it's become
you know earlier mornings than it used
to be and but it's really fun I mean we
take our families out on the road a lot
with us and it really is a family out
there I mean Isley's little daughter is
what three now she gets back all the
crew guys you'll see him you know
everybody in the mornin she's like the
mayor
but last year the news coming up in May
right yeah we've got we're going out on
tour they got actually Kelsea Ballerini
coming out with us and that's a great
line yeah this new guy Brett young he's
having a huge huge start and works in
California and Bakersfield at the end of
May May 26th and then it's six countries
three continents were going all over the
world we're so excited you're gonna like
it I hope you get to go on a safari
while you're there you've already
released you look good from that album
and the thing that strikes me they're
horns I never think of Lady Antebellum
in yeah I had a nice mixture whose idea
was that you know country music you know
people what are they gonna talk about
horns and if you go back to Johnny Cash
he had horns all over his stuff he has
these new forms and some songs and yeah
and it's I don't know it really does to
me it made the song oh I think so too
but last year you all did separate
projects and when I heard that you were
gonna do that I went oh this is the
beginning of the end they're not coming
back together was that a trial run or no
not really all there was never a way we
were not gonna reconvene it was truly
just we had worked for so many years
nine years almost non-stop we kind of
wanted a breath to spend time with our
families and kind of pursue a couple of
passion projects and always knowing that
we would come right back to where we
started
what's the best part of going to a big
awards night like the ACM I think seeing
friends I mean we're yeah we really
truly are best friends with all these
artists I mean Little Big Town Luke
Bryan I mean you know all of them really
is like it is a funny thing it's like a
little reunion you know we're gonna read
each other on and it's only time you get
to see each other too cuz you're all on
the road I know everybody thinks you
guys are together all the time you're
all in different parts of the country
yeah barely answers my phone calls
when you're not listening to your own
music or your friends are there other
genres of music that you like like I
mean I love Bruno Mars Justin Timberlake
ed Sheeran yeah I mean we're fans of
really all genres of music we're up by
the tenement when you hear another
artist release a great song what do you
have like a I've heard some some
musicians say they're like there's like
a combination of Ave a duration and envy
you know in Little Big Town they release
girl crush I thought it was such a bold
statement yeah and you know I would
we're not seeing vertex Karen and say
man I'm just I'm so I'm proud and
envious of you guys having the gumption
to put something like that that out
there and it does it makes you kind of
want to go hey man let's stop being
scared to say something and make a
statement and you know shows you want
yeah it does it does I mean when you
hear a great song of me die happy man
you know that I remember being down at
the beach and in a wedding in the
distance that was there you know first
dance and I texted Thomas I said you
know you've made it behind need you now
Bennett's point but I think one of the
coolest things is hearing what other
people's interpretations are because
we've been in meet and greets and met a
ton of the fans who are like my
husband's deployed and this song just
brings us together we miss each other so
much or it's about you know a past
relationship that you just can't quite
get over you know so I think that's one
of the coolest things about music though
people kind of make it their own
well good luck this year ladies
Antebellum song heart of the world you
had to pick one could you
[Music]
so happy for you guys congratulations on
your nomination - thank you we'll look
forward to your performance tonight were
you gonna be Stephen Colbert even on the
family we like that right there you can
watch the 52nd Academy of Country Music
Awards on Sunday April 2nd at 8 7
central right here on CBS